what's up everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout I am super excited to be
here with a special new guest he is the
bishop of the potter's house
he gives moving sermons every Sunday to
over 30,000 church-going members as well
as over 20 million people on lines a
crazy number
he is a master communicator an
entrepreneur a best-selling author with
over 40 books to his name a business
leader and he's got a new book out to
help entrepreneurs called soar Bishop TD
jakes welcome aboard man thank you a
real pleasure to be with you so I'm a
huge fan of your work I think I don't
know that there's any speaker who gets
more into the message when he's really
on point just feeling it and I think at
least once a week I'm telling somebody
on my team that I need to touch somebody
and run I'm pretty elevated things
pretty loudly that's true for those of
you who are watching who may not be as
familiar with Bishop Jake's work
I recommend go to his YouTube channel
type in touch somebody and run and watch
that video it's my favorite it's I think
a great introduction and thank you so
much for all the contribution you making
not just to the world but now also to to
entrepreneurship with your new books or
you know I'm excited to have the
opportunity to talk on the other side of
my head so much of what people do see
about me is is my faith and I came on
television and preaching but I've done
talk shows I've produced films over 500
million dollars grossing at the box
office so I do dabble over in the
entrepreneurial space and I grew up in
that environment and I finally decided
to kind of come out of the closet out of
the shadows and talk because so many
people in in my world are really trying
to launch businesses or figure out how
to launch businesses or having similar
troubles and struggles getting it off
the ground and I wrote sorta kind of
motivate and encourage people not to
give up and that trouble is a part of
the process and to encourage them to
buckle down and work through until you
get the thing off the ground and in the
air now we've linked to Barnes and
Nobles Amazon for everybody watching you
can go pick up the book it's
out yet though right it's still
pre-order is it out October the 10 so
we're just five days away you guys can
go check it out but you can pre-order
right now in the link below one of the
things I love about this story was when
you were talking about your father and
he had his his business of janitorial
business and he started with one one
bucket one mop and built it out but
never was able to go nationwide because
you said he refused to put down the mop
in the bucket could you share that story
because I think it's really insightful
and could really help my audience I use
it as a metaphor and it really inspired
me my father was what I would call the
the cereal hustler you know it's hard to
explain what all he did he did some of
everything in order to make ends meet
rent it so bad and then he got to the
point that he really zeroed in on
building a janitorial service starting
with the mop and a bucket and he ended
up with 52 employees back in 60s in West
Virginia that was really big but he
never could have lost you to the level
that it would have gone because he was
always so busy working on it he really
didn't have time to run it and I think
that's a common problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs they can't get their hands
off of the day-to-day things that they
have to do long enough to think through
the business from a CEOs perspective and
consequently they failed to be used for
their highest and best because they have
a tendency to hold on to the minutiae
and get away from the maximum things
that should be on your head if you
really building your business and so for
people who are going through that you
know they may not have entrepreneurs in
their family they may not have had
parents who are entrepreneurs and and
they don't know any better what's the
solution is it self education is it
reading books like how do you how do you
get them out of that mindset well I
think first thing you have to realize
there comes a point that your brain
becomes more important than your hands
and you have to figure out what point
that he is good leadership is working
yourself out of a job it might be more
profitable in the long run for you to
hire somebody to do what you used to do
while you kind of step back and rethink
where this is going how can i if I the
marketing value of this what
associations partnerships do I need to
build in order
to really exploit this business to take
it to the next level am I really
reaching the targeted audience or am I
just shooting shotgun pellets out into
the air and humbling that I like up and
hit somebody all these things require
some time getting around other people
who are doing what you're doing
having discussions with their big mentor
demanding a lot of times you don't have
time to do that because you are so pat
down but whatever your function is and I
am suggesting in the book that you might
be more valuable to your organization to
step away power somebody to do what you
were doing you might be more valuable in
the next capacity because the fruit is
out there on the tree it's not the one
that fell to the ground is the one that
you're about to pick and your hands have
to be free to get it I love that and now
in the building up you know the potter's
house and building your business who was
the first person that you hired like
what was their role what did they do for
you it was really it was really scary
for me I have 300 employees on the
church side of my business and on the
entrepreneur side of my business I have
less than 20 and oddly enough the model
of my business is built on partnerships
and I've talked about that the TD jakes
Enterprises survives because we have
partnerships with Sony Pictures we work
with Fox we've worked with lots of
people because they entertain the
business you don't always need to keep
full-time employees when you're not
filming so because it is a partnership
based business you want to keep your
overhead as low as possible so that your
profit margins can be highest and
functional we kind of operate that way
whereas in my not-for-profit world we
produce all of our everything graphic
artist desires our own marketing we even
have our own 18 wheelers we do contracts
with Walmart we we carry our merchandise
to them so it's much more of a practical
pragmatic traditional corporation those
two models give you two options and
there are many many more to which you
can do your business scale down the
employees scale up on the partnership or
bring everything in the house and
control the integrity of your brand from
a hands-on viewpoint so what somebody
has done but what advice you give to
entrepreneurs you're trying to figure
out which is the model for me which path
is better it's
there is no definite answer I think you
have to evaluate at different seasons
and in order to do that you have to be
free to do evaluations at cost
comparisons between what it would cost
to bid out the services versus hiring
the employee and sometimes it is true at
one Junction that it's better to do it
internally either because of financial
reasons or because of the quality
control issues that are developed other
times it is better to to farm it out and
use your people for better usage and in
order to do that that evaluation process
you've got to step away get the bids
from people who would come in and
replace your services and then evaluate
are they going to do it at a better
quality or they gonna do it at a better
price all of those are good reasons to
do it in the long run you don't have to
take benefits in the long run you don't
have to deal with the minutiae of
organizing the behind-the-scene struggle
because they're providing you a service
and you haven't evaluate is that the
best decision for you at this pad and
it's no cookie cutter answer it depends
on the business it depends on the
answers to those questions one of the
things I've learned most about
entrepreneurship and really about life
in general it almost pays a lot to come
to the table thing smart smart people
become smart people because they ask
questions it's not what you know it's
what you think to ask and asking the
right questions as a catalyst to get you
to the next dimension I love it now
thank you that you want to start a
movement with this book you you've
written 40 books you've had lots of
success meaning you've obviously built
up your church and other entrepreneurial
ventures why now like what's the
movement why now for 40 bucks like
what's the driving force behind this is
a time to launch this books or you don't
do things for profit you do things for
purpose and I think that this is a time
in the country that we desperately need
to rethink that where we're going as a
nation when you start looking at what is
really eating at the belly of the Rust
Belt states and you listen at the
groanings that are coming from the inner
city they are saying the same thing the
lack of opportunities the jobs that went
away are not coming back and if they do
come back we're not going to be equipped
to be on those jobs because of
automation the technology is
but the criteria and so we may be
waiting on a ship that's never going to
come in America has survived through
small businesses over 90 percent of the
employees in this country right now are
employed by companies with less than 500
employees so it's not about the big
fortune 500 companies coming back I have
a fob that that's good for economic
growth and it's good for the stock
market and all that but it's much more
pragmatic when it comes down to survival
and employee people on the streets are
much stronger done in smaller businesses
but I think we really mean to go back we
have become better consumers and we are
investors and so the whole notion of
pointing people toward entrepreneurship
gives you control you can live the life
you want you to make the kind of money
you want you can do it from home if you
want you can take care your children and
do it you can take classes at school
that still own your own business that
kind of flexibility you don't get every
day entrepreneurship depending on the
business will provide those
opportunities love it converted the
message my audiences too and secretly I
just want to get some questions we got
tons of people already lining up I've
been monopolizing the time but let's get
to some of the fan questions Jay Rhys is
writing in a bishop Jake's do you feel
entrepreneurship is a spiritual practice
I think that you benefit when you are a
spiritual person because
entrepreneurship is like riding a roller
coaster you sometimes up and sometimes
down and if you have no spiritual
equilibrium to stabilize your emotions
through the transitory process of
building a business you can be erratic
at home and with your kids within your
own life because you like the stability
to anchor yourself beyond the day-to-day
reports so from that perspective I think
it is very valuable the odd thing about
it is simply this people of faith I've
lived in that world a long time could
really benefit from better business
skills but people in business could
really benefit from having more faith so
I tried to merge those two ideas I'm
really not trying to convert you in this
book there's very little in this book
about faith but I really am targeting
this book too
people who are trying to rethink
redesign and relaunch the second half of
their lives or our tiredness beaten at
their mama's house and waking up at noon
eating cereal and they want to get back
into the market and there are no job
opportunities you may have to hire
yourself I like it next one coming in
Bishop Jake's what separates an
entrepreneur from a watcher preneur it's
the difference between having a dream
and having a goal a long-term preneur
has a dream an entrepreneur has a goal
as long as the dream has it has no date
it will always stay in euphoric realms
of our mind what to those who give you
who are want reproduce and you really
want to do it put a date on the mantra
preneur and you'll become an
entrepreneur holding your dream to a
dead land makes it a reality and not
something that you fantasize about every
time you're sick of your boss I like it
Hermione has a question I know you I
know you have a strong opinion on this
how do I evaluate my worth well you know
you cannot do that in a vacuum I get I'm
sitting in a room right now I can see
you on the screen I can see other people
in my office I can see the couch of the
chair the only thing I can't see is me
and that is a real problem
in evaluating your own worth you your
eyes are not designed to show you you so
what has to happen you have to determine
your own Worth and value by interviewing
people who interact with you and do
practical interviews what do you get
when you get me what is it that makes
you see value in me because sometimes
our opinions of ourselves are
overinflated sometimes they're
undervalued but when you talk to the
people with whom you have to do you get
a sense of what is the level of your
contribution you'd be shocked sometimes
it's not what you put your energy in and
and so in the book I have a point called
e to I ratio and its energy to impact
sometimes we're putting the greatest
energy into areas where we have the
least impact this sort of evaluation
helps you to reassociate that energy and
reallocate it to things where you could
have
as impact and sometimes you can't get
that done until you talk to the people
you do business with out to the people
who you live with and ask them the
candid question what is it about me that
is most effective sometimes the answers
will really show you have a lot of
pinions on mindset too which is great
basically legend communing sayings
worried that by profiting and having a
for-profit business he's selling his
soul so how do I get over that mindset
you know not unless he's selling little
dolls with pins in them that he's gonna
stick it in somebody into voodoo when
you have more resources money is a
nebulous thing it is what you do with
money that determines whether it's good
or evil we have more money you can send
help to the flood victims you can rescue
the people and for the Ricoh you can do
positive things with resources if you
don't have resources all you can do is
wish people will so whether having money
is a positive or a negative it will only
amplify who you are if you are not a
good person if you are selfish if
yourself consumed if you're suffering
grandma's money we'll just reveal that
all the more but if you are feeling
perfect if you have a loving heart and
he'll inherit money gives you more
options to be able to do that find a
better future for your children and I
think what the person is wrestling with
is a pro committee to think about guilt
and spiritual people often do that they
become guilty over their resources and
they think that money is evil if you're
a Christian you might point to things
like the Bible say if money is evil the
Bible didn't say money is evil
he said the love of money is a root of
all evil so what that saying is it is
your attitude about the money that
produces the evil and is not the money
itself it could be used to save the life
it could be used to find a cure for
cancer it's up to what you it's all
about how you direct it and so that
begins with your own inner self and
heart and so how do you get over that
because it's so common for entrepreneurs
to underprice themselves to not charge
with their worth to give their thing
away instead of charging for feelings
they're not worthy of it
how do I like so I hear the words I have
internalize that or like my audience
right how do we internalize that so you
do it first of all you have to do things
that fair market value the life is a bit
of a Robin Hood situation you're taking
from one person so that you can give to
another you choose your own charities
and it's important that we give some
give back but then give back has to be
budgeted as well I think it's good to
set up a budget of what you can afford
to give back annually set up a budget
for that operate within that budget like
you do everything else because if you
don't you're gonna you're gonna give
away the resources that you need to stay
afloat and this black jumping and a pool
to save somebody who's drowning that's
really amazing but drowning with them
really doesn't saved it so if you become
so philanthropic that you drown your
organization two of us laying there in
the water dead I appreciate the company
but I'd rather get out of the water
that's great Kiki is ready name about
the ministry but I think it applies all
entrepreneurs how do you sell you how do
you set yourself apart in a ministry
that is already so congested so many
ministries out there I think it relates
to every entrepreneur you get into the
business there's competition how do you
set yourself apart you know it's we're
really talking about branding and I'm
not branding is an overused word but
branding really makes you rethink what
do people get when they get you I think
a lot of people whether they're in
ministry or in business have not really
drilled down to specifically what is it
that you do that you're passionate about
but we use broad terms like I preach or
I do here or I build robots or whatever
it is you do but see if you go a little
bit deeper than that specifically what
what is it that when you do it it gives
you life and it gives you passion and
kind of hone in to a promise have seeds
were simple we do chicken right if
you're looking for a hamburgers don't
come here you know what are you gonna
hone in that you do right and do that
and you will distinguish yourself the
moment you define yourself you cannot be
all things to all people you can't
respond to all causes you have to choose
your lane and
in that Lane and brand yourself and
introduce yourself and describe yourself
with the synchronicity that allows
people to get a common picture in their
mind when they say when they see you
will this the uncover whether its habits
your way there are certain brands that
quickly when we hear this we say certain
things most people have not branded
themselves because they have not clearly
defined themselves I like that would you
say that the bishop TD jakes brand is
what do you world class act I think you
know my mantra for users and helping
hurting people and I think that gives me
the most passion is to be of service
when I feel like I did something whether
it's a movie a film a book or a ministry
that really helped people and added
value to their life it actually adds
value to mine I become demoralized if I
don't find a way to help you and that
has been consistent throughout all of my
life that I might be an asset in this
lifetime to the people I share the hair
with it's what I have dedicated my
entire life to he gets me out of the bed
every day and he keeps me going and
whether you experience me through the
talk show or through books over the you
excuse me at the ministry the
commonality is going to be I'm always
going to be uplifting I'm always going
to be trying to help you because I think
that my purpose in life is to help you
find yours if you had to pick one core
value like one word core value at the
center of Bishop TD jakes but with that
one would be loyalty loyalty and how
does that break down like what does
loyalty mean to you
loyalty means a whole lot of things it
means that if I'm your friend I'm the
friend you can trust it means that if
I'm in covenant with you I'll go down to
the wire whether things are going up or
down it loans it means that if I make
you a promise I'm going to do everything
I can to deliver on that promise
in my business of my corporations and my
partnership loyalty means that I'm in
for the long term play so people who are
in for the long term play don't try to
do short turn gimmicks to get over I'm a
long hollow sort of guy I've been
married 35 years I've been preaching 41
years I've been in the ministry since I
was 19 years old
consistency that's what loyal
is about to be a consistent promise you
can count on and that's what I've given
my life to do I love that maybe they've
had off your next bike loyalty
okay hey Bishop Jake's question what
would be a good method to network with
other people and put yourself out there
if you're an introverted or shy person
you know that that's an issue I think
social media becomes a great format to
start the dialogue because you can put
out at your discretion what you're
comfortable with and and then build
alliances but I think that we have
underestimated in this generation also
the practical pragmatic thing of sitting
down with people and it's social events
if you're an introverted person put a
time on it so you're not up under
pressure to come up with conversation
for a long time have a lunch with
somebody because you can talk about the
food talk about the weather it gives you
a mirror of things to talk about and it
gives you an ending date when you run
out of food it's over don't stay in your
food because men don't like candles that
have them under bushes if you are an
introvert you are still a candle you are
still a light and you can't you've got
to come out of hiding so that people can
see you by the way being introverted
doesn't mean that you can't be a public
figure the purest definition of an
introvert is I can go out and do things
in public but I am feared in isolation
so you want to be the man isolation but
you don't want to become so fat that you
don't everyone there exercise the
enrichment that happens from being alone
by sharing your gift with other people I
love it
next up is Monica question very excited
how do you stay strong when everything
around you is falling apart I think the
first thing you have to do is not base
your strength on the things around you
but the things within you you know a
ship doesn't go under because the water
is around it it was designed to float on
water around it it's only when the water
gets in it that the ship does now and so
you are never you will never rise or
fall based on the conditions around you
you can overcome those issues as long as
you don't let them get in you I'm
curious where I'll be in out like you
have
many great analogies in your sermons and
your interviews the ship the candle like
in every sermon is something do you
think in analogies like how do these
things come to you I'm just curious for
myself my mother was a teacher okay so I
grew up in the house with the teacher
and a teachers passion is to help you
know truth and any illustration that I
can use to help you better see truth and
people learn differently
some people are audio visual learners
some people learn through reading some
people learn through doing and so the
more I can find ways to get to you the
metaphor is the conveyor belt through
which I am delivering the truth I don't
want it to distract from the truth I
wanted to enhance the truth and you'll
see that in my book and I think is what
makes my books enjoyable readings
because I'm on subject but I use
everything around me to explain the
subject I'm talking about I love that
that even in the answer you talked about
a conveyor belt it's great I love it
it's fantastic okay Chris is right in to
say Bishop Jake's what are the first
three steps you would say are vital to
beginning an entrepreneurial venture
first three steps investigate one of the
things that I found when I started
researching this is that the likelihood
of successful business is not predicated
on the entrepreneur who needs money if
this if the when people who are in the
business because they need money the
stats are shocking and however rapidly
they go out of business you want to go
into business because you have found
something that somebody else needs okay
this is about supplying but someone else
demands so so the first thing I want you
to do is fine who has a demand for which
you can have an answer or a product
because when you find the person who
leads you your need to market goes way
down because if I'm thirsting for water
and you got water you don't have to have
a great sales pitch to sell it to me but
if I'm not thirsty you don't have to
talk to me a long time to get me to
drink something I don't want so fine who
wants what you have number too bad who
has done what you want to do because
sitting with them even for a moment if
you have to wash their car to get to
talk
finding out the pitfalls will save you
the time of going through things you
don't have to go we don't have to
reinvent the wheel twice the third thing
is find out the climate of other
businesses around you so that you can
partner your business in an environment
where wanting can be seen to it can be
appreciated and thoroughly it is
accessible by the people that you have
determined ever need for what you have I
love it point all right next question
think you're gonna like now I know
you've talked about having a vision how
important that is and that money runs
from blindness so Amanda's question
coming in is how do you create the
career you want when it does not exactly
exist yet that's the best I mean that's
why that's why I wrote the book the book
is built around around the Wright
brothers the audacity but these brothers
at a time that no airplane existed to
stand on the ground and think I belong
in the air the the whole analogy
throughout the book is built on that
question he just asked me we need to go
back to doing things that nobody has
done before building things that have
never been built before then innovation
is what has been at the inner structure
of America for years and years and years
and if we get away from that we are
defeated I am asking people to read the
book and be bodacious enough and have
the audition audacity not to just repeat
what you see everybody else doing but do
something fresh the Wright brothers
built their first airplane and she's not
in a bicycle shop and I'll use that in
the book to point to the fact you can
have a big idea and have small resources
you can deal from inadequate place and
still master a dream even when nobody
believes in it and even when you does
something that you don't have a name for
put it in the wind and let it soar I
love it I love it and we're aligned like
my logo is here on my chest it's a paper
airplane that's my company logo because
we had this idea we want to soar but we
don't have all the resources so we're
paper airplane we're not a fancy jet
taking off but we're gonna we're gonna
take off and get our idea happen
Paul is ready then to say question for
Bishop Jake's if you've been divine
define success by one act in your life
what would that be
let me start with this and give him the
definition that I must often give for
success success for me is never about
how much money you make or where you
live or what you drive or who you
associate with success for me it's when
I when I take what was in my head and
bring it to the point that it stands in
front of my face the birthing of an idea
the fulfillment of a concept is success
to me I give them a personal
illustration I sit around a boardroom
and we were trying to figure out what it
would be like to take our Women's
Conference at our Men's Conference and
put them together at the same time so
their families wouldn't have to play a
two plane tickets to come to an event we
didn't have a name for it then we were
gonna call it manifests somebody had a
proprietary usage over the name we ended
up calling it megafest fast forward 12
months later I'm standing in the Georgia
Dome the World Congress Center in the
Philips Arena with over a hundred
thousand people jammed impact into
Atlanta that success what started in my
head is not in front of my face and
whatever your be city is whether it's to
raise good kids whether it's to be a
good father whether it's to build a
building a company or or Church you
can't be successful if your dream dies
in your head you've got to get it out in
front of your face so that you can see
it materialized that is it says I love
that yeah I think my mind if one a was
touch somebody and run for me 1b is the
birthing of an idea the way you did on
Oprah's master class and so guys go
check that one out if you haven't seen
Bishop Jake's and burthen of an idea
it's a must-see here's a question that
that's interesting how do you help
somebody else so someone in my school
who's always alone sitting on a chair I
think this can be a bigger question to
like you see someone who might need help
but you're afraid judgement fear
whatever it is like you're afraid of
something how do you reach out and help
somebody that you see is in need the
worst thing they can do is say no if
you're a friend like that should never
be a good entrepreneur you never
able to do anything if they're the
person who's in discomfort you have to
be the bigger person and walk over and
say hello or you want to come eat with
me or you know that's yours of my salad
you're having what made you order that
starting a conversation with people is a
ministry within itself and you have to
be courageous enough let's let's take
this question to the next level we must
everybody doing us right now must be
cured right now from the fear of
rejection because you will never be
exceptional and you will never succeed
if you are bound by the fear of
rejection the worst they can do is say
no I am living proof you can survive and
no you can't survive no but it would be
terrible to go to the grave with maybe I
love it I feel a sermon coming on I love
it I love it
it's crazy how quickly half an hour
flies by when you having fun and talking
shop your books coming out October 10th
see or Bishop TD jakes again the links
are in the description what's the one
message takeaway that you want people to
get from reading the book I want to
start a revolution I want to see our
country building again I want to see our
business is thriving again I want to
give hope to the inner city and the rest
of ourselves states that you are the
help you've been waiting on come up with
your dream and get it up into the air
and then don't let the turbulence make
you cancel the flight I love that that
there's that metaphor again thank you so
much makes for spending your time with
us today thank you guys so much for
watching this will be on you can watch
it repeat afterwards you can get the
messages back to you really appreciate
everybody's time have a fantastic rest
of the day and we'll see you soon all
the best birthdays